that's what it is to feel like when
you're non-binary and I wanted to write
a powerful song about it and that's what
this song is waste of space
[Music]
[Applause]
that was a snippet of g-flip's new song
waste of space and joining us now is G
flip hi what's up Kathy how you doing uh
you got a little injury here yeah I've
got a little chicken wing going on Yeah
I broke my hand a broken hand and you're
a drummer how is that working out for
you well yesterday I had a really fun
day yesterday I was putting in my studio
learning how to set up my drum kit fully
like left side heavy so left-handed
because I've got a lot of shows coming
up but I broke my hand and then six
hours later I was on stage playing a
show so I didn't let it stop
we had going on
life is all about challenges and we
learn as we go what we can do that we
never thought we could and for you it's
learning to play drums with one hand and
I've successfully learned how to tie my
shoelaces one-handed you can go check it
out on my tick tock
myself
[Music]
impressive well congratulations your new
track waste of space the lyrics are so
powerful the question that you're asking
in this have you ever felt like a waste
of space what was the moment that this
song came to you
um I wrote this song later last year
um it has to do with my gender identity
and me coming to turn terms with that as
a kid and now I identify as non-binary I
use they them pronouns as a kid I got a
bullied because I would wear the boy's
uniform to school
and then I'd hang out with the boys that
I was in a friendship group in when I
was about seven years old always hanging
out with the dudes playing footy Pokemon
cards everything and then one day they
were like you're a girl even though I
had like short hair boys uniform looked
just like them but they one day said I
can play with them so then I walked over
to the girls wearing dresses and then
they said I couldn't play with them
because I was a boy so then I was stuck
in the middle and they'd call me a waste
of space and in terms of the binary and
being non-binary I feel like I am that
in the middle of uh you know both
genders just a mix of that and it that's
what it is to feel like when you're
non-binary and I wanted to write a
powerful song about it and that's what
this song is waste of space the artwork
is the sweetest throwback of you how old
were you in that photo
I reckon I was about probably seven or
eight years old yeah what would you tell
your seven or eight year old self or
when you look back at that photo what
comes to mind
I wanted to use that artwork because I
feel like
in everyone who identifies now as
non-binary they have a photo of them as
a kid where it's like you look at that
photo and you're like you know that's
who I was I was like that little
backwards cat wearing little punk that I
always wanted to be but then Society you
know fills you with lots of information
of like you have to be female so
everyone I was looking up to was like
the Pussycat Dolls like JLo Shakira love
all of those artists but that wasn't me
I was like this little boy's clothes
wearing like rough little kid and I
didn't have that representation so when
I look back at that that picture of me
as a kid
um you know
um I I don't know I look at that and I'm
like that is exactly who I was wearing
that cap and that t-shirt
um and I wanted to use that as an
artwork how would you describe the
artist you are now I get vibes just
personally from you of Gwen Stefani
meets Travis Barker
a mighty mix Cassie
um yeah definitely like uh some of
Gwen's stuff like like 90s early 2000s I
was like obsessed with obviously Travis
Barker
um he's one of my heroes actually he did
some shows with uh another Benny has
plus 44 with a broken right
hand or wrist and so definitely before I
played my shows on the weekend with
broken hand I watched him
so yeah you yeah you say yeah Gwen
Stefani Travis Barker had a little baby
maybe it would be funny
when did you first pick up the stakes
um I was about nine years old
started my my cousin played drums and I
was obsessed with uh his drum kit but I
never wanted to play it because I didn't
know how to play it but I'd always like
leave the lunch table at family
gatherings and just be like staring at
his drum kit and then my Auntie and
Uncle for my ninth birthday surprised me
with a little blue drum kit and that
honestly is the best day of my life it
was like my whole life began that day
now another song of yours get me out of
here yeah I like it's such a Vibe it's
such a jam yeah zero F's to give is that
the 2022 vibe that we have right now the
mindset yeah I think so I think just
um no F's to give you can't swear on
this candy no no
uh yeah I guess like
in life things people are gonna throw
stuff at you people are going to try to
bring you down social media is going to
try to bring you down but like you just
gotta not care about it you have the
hottest co-star in your music video
Forget Me Out of Here how much fun did
you and krishelle have on set we had so
much fun on set like we still like talk
about that day and how much fun we had
and now every time we go into a 7-Eleven
we're like should we start making out
but yeah no it was so it was so fun and
easy and especially the crew that I work
with
um the production team I work with and
my creative director you know they're
all Queer and it was such a beautiful
safe space and just a awesome clip to
make some crazy art you know krishelle
told us recently that she was scared to
kind of maybe document your relationship
you know on selling sunset with the
cameras were you at all hesitant to put
krishelle in the music video because it
is something that's going to live on
forever it's your art you're mixing your
personal professional life yeah
um I I wasn't nervous about it as long
as she was comfortable with doing it and
she actually came up with like the
creative like forward creative ideas
because she's got such a creative brain
I know she's like sells houses and just
is an all-round boss but like she's so
creative and like really good at writing
and like storytelling and everything so
uh she helped come with the creative
with it and as long as she was
comfortable like then I was stoked so
and like she's got acting chops because
her like soaps and stuff me I don't so
it was really nice having a co-star that
like just like when the camera's a go
it's just ready to go so like she's a
superstar isn't that the best though
when you meet someone and you can mix
your personal and professional life and
they help elevate it to team it's the
there's no greater feeling than that
yeah it was it's super fun and she's
just she's so awesome how would you feel
about cameras around for your guys's
relationship would you want to put it on
selling sunset or do you want to keep it
private
um I I don't know for me I I'm not
really like
I never thought of my life as being on a
reality like show well you know
um I think I want to stick to the music
you know I don't want people to know me
as like a reality star rather than like
the musician because my whole life I've
been playing music since I was nine
years old and that's always been my
dream and I always just want to be in
studios or on stage playing drums and
stuff so I don't think it's really for
me but like support Coachella and I love
the whole cast I've met the whole cast
of selling Sunset and you know the
creators behind it um and they're all
such rad awesome human beings and yeah
they're so great they're so fun that's
why I wanted to ask you that question
because you do strike me as someone who
it wants to protect their art in a way
that not having other people think that
you have other motives and whatnot what
is next for you you've been performing a
lot with a broken arm you've been
performing what is next
what is next well uh obviously wasted
spaces out now go Stream It Go watch the
music video that's really powerful
um I've got some big shows coming up
I've got my biggest show coming up in
Australia which is going to be in front
of like I don't know 20 30 000 people
and I've just freshly broken my arm my
hand so trying to work out how to do a
really large scale show one-handed I
can't wait to see the show in Australia
I won't be there but I'll be able to see
it from afar and I know that if anyone's
gonna crush it with a broken hand it is
gonna be you my friend thank you so much
thank you Cassie I really appreciate the
interview mate of course and again
g-flip's latest track waste of space is
out now I'm a waste of space
that is saying
[Music]